لكن هناك جالي خاصه بالنسبه للمشاركه
العربيه وديع هناك جاليه عربيه مقيمه في
قطره في البلدان القليله القريبه من قطر
على غرار الامارات او المملكه العربيه
السعوديه نتحدث عن هذه المشاركه العربيه
وتواجد تونس المغرب قطر للمره الاولى
وايضا المنتخب السعودي في هذه في هذا
المذيعه
بشكل خاص تونسي اسمه صابر مقيم هنا في في
الدوحه منذ عده سنوات يقول ستتفاجئ قال لي
ستتفاجا
المشجعين التونسيين سيكون هناك عدد كبير
من التونسيين من التونسيين الحقيقيين كما
قال لي وليس من جليات اخرى
سنكون بكثره همم نتابع سنناصر المنتخب
التونسي بقوه
المنتخب التونسي يلعب يوم الثلاثاء
المنتخب المغربي همم فيما بعد اذن سيصلون
شيئا فشيئا لا لا لا لا راينا حقيقه امس
مساء على الكورنيش في الدوحه امام
الفانزون همم المنطقه المخططه للمشجعين
التي افتتحت بشكل رسمي كان هناك عدد همم
من همم
المشجعين التونسيين ترون حاليا حفظ
الافتتاح من خلفه وبعض الالعاب الناريه
التي بدات تظهر همم
كي يعود الى المشجعين ان التونسيين همم هم
متواجدين حاليا هنا بالنسبه همم للمشجعين
المقيمين غدا في الدوحه ولكن سيصلون همم
من دول اخرى على الارجح فيها الايام
القليله المقبله ونفس شيء بالنسبه للمغرب
وايضا للسعوديه همم ربما في الساعات
الاخيره ايضا قبل انطلاق المباراه الاولى
لمنتخباتهم الوطنيه
شكرا لك وديعه
الخاص الى